do you think it's a better scenario that
citizens are being defenselessly run
over by tanks from their government as
opposed to a civil war scenario where
they fight back so because they're
completely defenseless right now and
they're getting bazooka to high heaven
you think they should have no way to
defend themselves
top five lessons learned from Venezuela
me ask you this what have you learned
most from the story unfolding in
Venezuela everyone's been talking about
bar this has been a little lost in the
shuffle yeah nothing surprising no right
yeah they've really taught us a lot so
obviously they've reached a boiling
point
right the citizens been staging massive
demonstrations against the dictator Matt
Maduro how do you pronounce the name of
the legitimate president
oh gosh I don't know well you know it
was very hard for me to watch properly
one president want good good oh good god
I don't know anyway
there have been demonstrations going on
obviously against a kid in Maduro
yes not recognized so there's so one the
other guy recognized as the interim
president by both the United States this
is important to note and other nations
actually I think we have a clip and a
freeze here in Scituate we just can't
show it because they've been running
over dissidents with tanks and Maduro is
for people who have been follow me give
you a brief history lesson he's a
socialist turned dictator but I repeat
myself better yes civilians and this is
this is what's so important people say
well ha no this is an example of pure
socialism okay the most tragic thing
here is that it is entirely predictable
this isn't the first time this kind of a
government has run out you blow over
with tanks milk and and before you say
that it's not true socialism let me walk
you through the top lessons we've
learned as to why it is lesson number
five by the way is that democratic
socialists are gonna hate lessons for
through one and the marks a page join up
at Mudd Club by the way because we're it
and everything's demonetised on iTunes
so the fourth lesson that I think is
most important is that socialism doesn't
work and I know there's a lot of people
say well this is it
no no halt second we're not talking
about about places like Venezuela
actually do you know how I know you
Bernie Sanders and celebrities have long
pray
and other South American socialist
country what they did it when their
economies seemed to work
way back in most of 1961 they invaded
Cuba and everybody was totally convinced
the Castro was the worst guy in the
world all the Cuban people who were
absolutely a billion against Fidel
Castro they'd forgot that he educated
the kids gave them health care totally
transformed ah you know it's funny
sometimes American journalists talk
about how bad the country is because
people are lining up for food that's a
good thing in other countries people
don't line up view is skewed because
there's no line up in the prune juice
aisle by the way argue that it's not
real so do you know how I know that it's
not true still today okay Bernie still
has an article on his website today
right now that claims Venezuelans are
living the American dream better than
the United States today now right now
right now and I guarantee you after this
show they probably wait two weeks until
this blows over and then remove it and
then you can time machine go back to
today right now this Thursday what's the
date May seculars there may 2nd 2nd
still says on Bernie Sanders website
official website that Venezuelans are
living the American dream is that lining
up for a toilet paper and having to eat
dogs because you're starving to death I
don't remember that being the American
you cannot you cannot simply say it's
not real socialism because it doesn't
work now you praised it Bernie still
praises it this is what you wanted it's
what you got it's over you're done screw
your attempted pivot to Denmark they
don't want you Maduro was he was elected
yeah if you say it was a special
election because Chavez died fine
so did Chavez was elected you asked was
it you were tipped a little bit by
endorsements from one Jeff Spicoli and
Bernie Sanders still pretty thin free
yes sorry leftist you can't blame you
can't blame this on corrupt leaders now
when your system this is what the system
of socialism is what grants them
unbridled power in the first place the
fact that a socialist turns into a
dictator because you created the sole
environment where he can become an
all-powerful dictator is your fault yes
and we already did a video debunking
John Oliver's lies specifically
Venezuela why it failed you can watch it
on the channel but let me give you kind
of a brief summary for people to
understand they try
say well it's about the economy okay
Venezuela most oil-rich country in the
world yeah more so than Saudi Arabia a
lot of people don't know this yeah
Chavez reserves have the state run the
oil industry instead of investing it
back into the oil industry right fessing
profit for the economy to grow other
sectors they used it to pay for a ton of
socialist programs that people liked him
for a while creating a bubble that burst
when the oil market didn't do that well
so what was a road bump for the
capitalist economies was an absolute
disaster for Venezuela try so before
these protests this is what's important
to know right now you see them being run
over with tanks and shot by their
government it seems severe but before
this they were starving gift they were
digging through trash for food yeah
pretty mother says it is the only way
he's getting no no at least we have not
died of hunger
yeah his likes having to do this he says
he finds food that is edible
so socialism doesn't just kill people by
running them down with them with tanks
it starves them first yeah important and
I don't want to be simplistic so let me
let me back this up gun rights are
necessary for a free society essential
so here you can see someone on MSNBC
suppress actual emitting that
Venezuelans are completely powerless
because they don't have gun rights you
have to understand in Venezuela gun
ownership is not something that is open
to everybody so if the military have the
guns power and as long as Nicolas Maduro
controls the military he controls the
country oh did I just say that that
would never happen to you though come on
now whatever happens it was that Tucker
Carlson that's it I know what people are
going to say that people been saying
this non-stop on social media like what
it's what they call the reverse Nirvana
fallacy I think they call it that and
either in either rhetoric lodging or
philosophy I don't know which is taught
in college remember I learned about this
in college well the idea like that well
Hall a second day if they had guns do
you think it would fix the problem here
the government has tanks okay hold on a
second so let's begin the statistics so
let me ask you this do you think it's a
better scenario that citizens are being
defenselessly run over by tanks from
their government as opposed to a civil
war scenario where they fight back so
because they're completely defenseless
right now and they're getting bazooka to
high heaven
you think they should have no way to
defend themselves III don't understand
the argument and by the way it's also
incorrect with an unarmed population
material was barely hanging on to power
yeah okay
feed um 300 million guns with a mix he'd
be through yeah they're doing rocks and
bottles right now can you imagine if
they were armed any ideas like well they
would just nuke but no no there's a
ground war that needs to be fought and
right now they are fighting without guns
and the Second Amendment is designed
specifically this is where people mess
it when they talk about it being hunting
I know I sound like a broken record but
it's designed specifically to prevent
this kind of government from even
attempting this sort of tyranny but that
would never happen here yeah that's the
old it would never happen here so let's
just make sure that we have no failsafe
the United States an example if you look
at the numbers we have a population of
320 something million people yeah we
have 300 something million guns I think
it's over 3000 yeah 30 percent of
households yeah who own guns our total
military population is just over 2
million that's including active and
reserve personnel yeah
there's no chance of the United States
gunning down its people because they
know the citizenry is so armed it cannot
happen and if you think again
youyou think that genocide is better in
Venezuela than a civil war I need to
hear your argument when you say that
guns in the hands of civilians wouldn't
help I just don't agree just like we
have a historical precedent for all
socialist Marxist communist governments
doing this the arms pot armed
populations fighting people Switzerland
weren't invaded during World War two and
I know some of you will say well they
had a geographical advantages the
mountainous regions okay but you know
what let's use another example direct
quote from Japanese military when they
were asked why they didn't invite the
United States after Pearl Harbor said
there would have been a gun behind every
blade of grass by the way Japanese very
flowery what's your Excuse Hirono
[Applause]
whatsoever this is what's so important
it's it's so pretty there's nothing
unique about Venezuela all it would be
if you could find an exception
no all big government and socialist
leaders disarm their citizens yes
everything I hope you in a Cuban Nazi
Germany so socialism with socialism
disarmament is the rule not the
exception what lesson number two this
one is kind of an aside but I want to
include it is it
and the Trump is in a rush Institute my
important one though so this is really
simple Putin is supported Maduro openly
and repeatedly
Madrid was actually reading a plane did
you have to escape to Cuba yeah he was
out before before the Russians convinced
him not to and I back in in in January
Trump issued a statement officially
recognizing one other guy and by the way
it's also important to note that you
know Russia's had a cozy relations with
with Cuba and if you look at Donald
Trump and Bolton then they're not only
their sanctions but their rhetoric on
Cuba again this just backs it up but if
you don't believe me and I don't think
you should believe you should net will
just lead to the fire don't believe your
lying eyes and believe your lion ears
here's President Trump meeting with one
other guy's wife telling her that her
husband is one hundred-percent the
president when asked about Russia by the
way he couldn't be more clear we are
with Venezuela we are with your husband
Regina and with the people that he
represents which is a big big majority
of the country what's your next question
it couldn't be more forceful not only
the socialism not work but the macro
really works socialism is outright evil
and I've talked about this many times
that's not compassionate no Maduro is
army they're running people down in the
streets shooting the Neth this is where
socialism always ends how is there any
question as to this being pure evil
Venezuela again it's not an outline oh
the 20th century socialist Marxist
regimes have killed over a hundred
million people tell that to your edgy
atheist friend who talks about all
religions being fought in the nay all
all Wars being fought in the name of
religion yes I don't understand please
answer me how is this a surprise to
anyone if only we had the literal exact
comparison of a Marxist out-of-control
government running over dissidents with
tanks hmm in the history books but is it
possible somewhere maybe you starting to
get the picture and these
this is the issue if you go to Rand Paul
that Senator Rand Paul a little bit
socialism it starts with it can only
function was an entirely powerless and
entirely defenseless society well yeah
the two are different things when I say
powerless I mean people who are reliant
on the government for their health care
reliant on the government for their
education reliant on the government for
their welfare for their ability to live
you sucked in a soul straight from
somebody's body when I talk about
defenseless I'm talking about systemic
disarmament and one of course precedes
the other this is one thing to that that
you can't I think Thomas soul talked
about this you can't blame the leaders
who seize control that you've willingly
given it given to them you can at some
point maybe it was democratic but guess
what at some point it's not going to be
let's not say Bernie Sanders is a Maduro
I don't think he would be maybe not the
next guy but it could be the next guy
and the next guy and then that's guy and
you're too far in because you're
dependent on the government based on
these policies because you thought you
were getting at gimme and let me let me
something else here that I think is
important to note capitalism is not
flawless no one here is or something
that free enterprise of course has its
problems but if I'm wrong and this is
the issue the idea of dispersing power
but not being centralized if I'm wrong
and Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos are
corrupt and they become like Maduro so
you know what thousands of people lose
their jobs the economy is going to do
pretty poorly yeah it'll be catastrophic
economically for a lot of people if
you're wrong people get starved and run
over with tanks so if you're gonna take
the lesser of two evils let me know what
you pick hey there if you like this
video subscribe or click one of these
videos playing in a box you know what
hit the notification bail because
subscriptions don't really mean anything
anymore
especially if you're not 18 or older at
the very least logged in to YouTube as a
teen or older because sometimes people
are 25 but they don't know how to use
the YouTube system properly and then you
never just take the notification pal or
you hate yourself